bonjour à tous est liée à camiri et je
suis avec brut pour ces activistes se
fait arrêter n'est pas un problème
car pour eux il est temps d'agir
maintenant
et leurs méthodes font parler d'eux
[Musique]
il est aux fraises
aujourd'hui avec brut on va vous
raconter l'histoire d'un tout misé
mouvement écolo radical qui fait
beaucoup parler de lui en ce moment
extinction réveillant et
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est là
la chose
[Musique]
moi on est en novembre 2018 à londres et
les activistes que vous venez de voir
viennent de bloquer les cinq principaux
ponts de la ville
leur but est clair faire parler d'eux en
ralentissant l'économie de la capitale
du royaume uni
[Applaudissements]
un cri santo
non
d
[Applaudissements]
on
22 km
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il fit praxis tobo 2000 inc igilgili
[Musique]
l'homme que vous venez de voir faire la
leçon à un policier britannique c'est
l'un des fondateurs du mouvement
extinction rébellion il s'appelle roger
allam
c'est un ancien agriculteur bio et
chercheur en désobéissance civile le
chercheur au king's collège de londres
décident de mettre en pratique ses
recherches et organise dans la fac une
manif musclée contre les dirigeants de
l'établissement qui l'accusent de
maltraiter la planète c'est en février
2017 et ça se passe comme ça
normal pour cette opération roger allam
et un élèves ont fini au poste
ils ont été poursuivis pour dégradations
pour finalement être acquitté
american crime a lancé
bbx le mouvement extinction rébellion à
trois principales revendications la
reconnaissance de la gravité de
l'urgence des crises écologiques actuels
et une communication honnête à ce sujet
en gros ils veulent que les
gouvernements reconnaissent les menaces
qui pèsent sur la planète et prennent
leurs responsabilités
de facture
[Musique]
les hacktivistes demandent aussi une
réduction immédiate des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2020 soit enfin il
demande la création d'une assemblée
citoyenne chargé de décider des mesures
à mettre en place pour atteindre ses
objectifs
vous avez déjà peut-être croisé ce sigle
dans la rue eh bien c'est normal car il
a été pensé pour ça immédiatement
identifiable et faciles à reproduire le
logo d'extinction rébellion évoque un
cercle qui représente la terre avec à
l'intérieur un sablier qui représente
l'urgence qu'il ya à ge et vous allez
voir leurs militants préparent
minutieusement leurs actions
[Musique]
non
oui
le mouvement extinction rébellion à un
principe de base la désobéissance civile
c'est à dire ne pas respecter une loi de
manière publique collective et non
violente pour défendre une cause quitte
à se faire arrêter par la police
et pour mettre en application cette
désobéissance civile non violente tous
les moyens sont bons
sitting blocage de ponts de routes les
opérations d'extinction rébellion selon
tipis et prennent de plus en plus de
place dans les médias
et forcément ça plaît pas à tout le
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
extinction rébellion ixair pour les
intimes a à peine un an d'existence et a
déjà des ambassadeurs plutôt connu au
moins 22 femmes mexicain america to want
to be or not to be
extinction rébellion c'est donc des
porte-paroles vip et des activistes aux
profils très variés comme brut a pu le
constater dans son qg londonien
après nombre extinction rébellion a
désormais des antennes à paris berlin
madrid bruxelles
aujourd'hui ces militants s'organisent
pour que leurs messages chocs fasse
bouger les gouvernements et les citoyens
du monde entier
[Musique]
ah oui
il
ménard
c'est rare
[Musique]
sa richesse
on ne sort pas
il ya urgence et ce n'est pas telle
sanction rébellion qui le dit loulou
donne jusqu'à 2020 pour agir et 2020
c'est demain
[Musique]